like I'm not afraid of anything in this
world other than not being because how
could it be that in a matter of three
months you are married to a woman of 15
years and you just get married
again just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends as you guys know me and my wife
done a reaction video to brother khed
and sister Sal's divorce sad news which
we don't want on any family unit because
it breaks the breakdown of the family
unit has an impact a ripple effect on
communities so subh in this video I
wanted to touch upon a few doubts or
rumors spreading but mainly the question
question I wanted to ask was why did
Brother khed move on so fast and mention
to you sisters inshallah to understand
from a man's perspective three to four
reasons why a man moves on so fast and
we want to tackle these issues why my
dear sisters I'm not here to make you
upset anxious worried you know look at
marriage in a way that you don't you're
scared of getting married no rather I
want to inform you and inform you so
that you can make rational decisions I
know you guys are emotional that's how
you guys are created you have your
hormones imbalances Etc many other
things alhamd we have those hormonal
issues as well with testosterone so you
know it uh it affects us in a different
way it affects you guys in a different
way but if you listen and listen to
learn rather than listen to reply we
will all benefit from this inshallah so
in a recent podcast there's some things
that brother khed said that he really
fears so I want to touch up on this
because it's very very important because
for him to make this decision of going
their separate ways and then moving on
so fast despite the fears that he had
let's watch what could be the causes of
a man moving so fast and to me I found
it a bit bizarre that the fact that he
moved on so fast after being married 15
years but again we'll come to any minute
like religion is a big part of my life
Spencer for those for those don't know
and for me like the five daily prayers
being able to Center myself being able
to you know just remember why I'm here
being able to feel safe that in Allah's
protection you know for me that's
probably the most important thing in my
life yeah alhamdulillah just being able
to sort of Center myself in prayer and
get away from the chaos and the noise
and everything that's going on for me
that's probably the most important thing
I journal every night so for me just
writing down the three things I'm
grateful for the one thing that I want
to let go of so just reminding myself
constantly about what it is you know
alhamdulillah it keeps me focused I do
struggle with some things sometime like
life is not perfect I struggle a lot
with you know overthinking about things
I struggle a lot with you know getting
anxious about things like every day I
want to let go of something and you know
every day there's a different struggle
that might pop up at some point in time
so for me it's just about being able to
write that down and be like you know I'm
going to let go of you today that fear
of my kids' future like I'm not afraid
of anything in this world other than not
being there for my kids so I was always
afraid will someone take care of my kid
the way I would
well that's a child of determination
will Society treat him in the way that I
would in this country
yes he will be protected he will be
taken care of he will get opportunities
there will be resources for him it gives
me peace so guys you saw that for
yourself subh Allah Every Man's worst
nightmare is what that another man is
going to raise their kids you know who
this man is you don't know how is is he
is he safe you know is is is my kid safe
around him Etc any man fear is that
that's why if you notice Subhan Allah
majority of the time a lot of men do not
initiate divorces sadly it's made well
non-muslim statistics is 80 to 90% women
initiate divorces and we know that in
the Muslim Community as well that men
have the power of talak for this very
reason Allah subh has the wisdom and he
has given the power of talak to the man
because a man can make rational
decisions uh rather than just ask talak
every two seconds or give talak every
two seconds now one of the reasons
brothers and sisters the first reason
for a man to go his separate ways and
move on so fast can be that he is
married to someone who is really really
bad and he tries his best over and over
again Subhan Allah sisters and like I
said before we need to deal with the
reality yes okay sometimes we know a lot
of cases men are quite violent in
marriages both men and women are as
violent but men use more lethal Force so
we know that's a fact yeah so what I'm
going to mention to you next shouldn't
really bother you sisters yeah women are
known to initiate divorces majority of
the time sadly that's a reality when
women carry on you know oh I want to
divorce I want to divorce I want to
divorce I want to divorce a man has
enough a point where it's enough or if
the woman is a really you know an evil
woman who's making his life help now
again I'm not saying that sister Sal is
like that I'm not saying that I'm just
saying generally for men this can be a
reason for him to not only get divorced
but move on so fast in a matter of
months that's number one number two when
issues happen in the household when
people get arguments Etc whatever you
need to understand something sometimes
couples take their space Etc whatever or
they just don't want to see each other's
face for whatever reason but one thing
you need to understand my dear sisters
is a man a man's sexual desire is not
the same as a woman yes okay it's very
rapid it's very instant and it is uh you
know quite hard and we know from the
evidences from the Quran and Sunnah the
fitner of a man towards a woman this
it's our biggest weakness to me the the
thing that I want to mention is that or
a man if you boycott him or whatever you
don't want to talk to him Etc and he's
waiting a month and two months and 3
months and four months and he's thinking
hold on a second there's no contact for
and maybe she just thinking you know
what I don't know I'm waiting for him to
message first Etc no no no no no you
don't do that to a man let me tell you
something because that's the reason why
the Hadith says if a man calls his wife
the bed and she refuses the angel curs
her why because she is actually
blackmailing him with sex one of his
biggest weaknesses it's like a man using
his power that he has as a is more
physically stronger to put his wife in a
dangerous position and then defend her
she's at her most vulnerable and weak
and she needs your help and Aid if a
guy's got a knife or whatever trying to
harm her and you are there just watching
and thinking no so do you see how
vulnerable each one is in different
situations so for sisters to think that
you're going to let your husband go
without intimacy and think that he's not
going to get married again have a second
wife end it with you and got get married
again you are absolutely deluded reason
number three could be polygamy it can be
a possibility it a speculation and the
reason I'm saying the speculation is
because obious you guys know sisters
know me you know I'm one of the most
hated Brothers in the daene for speaking
this Troth I don't really care I'm not
here to you know please any or anyone
this the H every man is polygamist by
Nature please understand that do not
hate it do not fight it it's a
testesterone plays a big role in our
sexual drive you need to understand we
don't choose to do this we are created
in this manner you can look at people
who are married to you know really
beautiful woman you know Beyonce Kim
Kardashian you know and they still cheat
on them why because it is like that's in
our biology if a woman marries a man who
is her dream man she will never ever
think of another man ever and you women
know that if you get your man that you
really want whatever it is to dark and
hamon whatever your criteria is for that
matter but it's not the same with the
man a man can be married to his dream
girl and yet he will still want another
woman so this might be the case in this
situation brother khed and Sal situation
that he opened up to her he wanted to
get a second wife and Etc and she said
Over My Dead Body Etc because women
don't understand this they're emotional
understandable is painful again though
what happens is you destroy your
marriage and then what happens what's
going to happen after you've got two
free kids it is it can be difficult for
you to get married and the thing is why
destroy your family because of this and
what happens for us me is we try to
reason we try to say look we want to do
it openly we don't want to hide it this
one of the reasons Brothers men sadly go
down the roof hiding their secret second
wives Etc this is the reason why because
the first wife causes problems you're
not going to see the kids I'm going to
make your life hell I'm going to get the
government against you blah there are
sisters who accuse and falsely accuse
their ex-husbands of being connected to
some terror group because of this this
is how Wild it gets and that's why
Muslim men are thinking I have these
desires I've been married for 15 years I
have the desire of another woman and
she's telling me she's going to make me
no problem I'm going to keep it hidden
this could be a reason that he had a
discussion with her she said over a dead
body it's a speculation again and he
thought okay no problem go separate ways
whatever is for that matter and then for
him to get move on that fast I'll be
honest which I was a bit shocked to move
on that fast it's it's not right if I
was married to my wife for 15 years I'll
be honest with you I would not move on
that fast not that fast I mean is it
haram no it's totally Halal and I wish
the best and may Allah protect his
marriage and give him the best in this
life and the Hereafter his new marriage
aldah but this is what you need to
understand sisters when you go down this
route of being irrational emotional and
push your husband to that level he is
going to look look that's is desire that
he has he's either going to commit Zena
or he's going to be go behind your we
and a real man a coward would go z a
fearing his wife a real man would go and
get married again and if you leave the
picture or threet and leave the picture
is going to say okay no problem I'm so
sorry I want you in my life I can still
look after you take care of you but I
want to get married again getting
married again doesn't mean he doesn't
love you okay we don't operate the way
you guys operate just because you think
oh my gosh if I was to think of another
man I don't love him anymore we don't
operate the way you operate we can love
our wives die for them and still want to
get married again which I've been
telling our sisters that's the third
reason could be and the fourth reason is
that it happens rarely but a man falls
in love with another woman and sadly
this is not right again you know
especially that if he is is going to
abandon his first wife and again it's
not Haram but you have polygamy I mean
you can choose both options but some men
are like you know what no I don't that
despise or whatever and I just want to
move with another woman these are the
four reasons it might be the reason
because to me to see brother High I
really wanted to find out why did he
move on so fast it doesn't add up Allah
subhana knows best but to me I'll be
honest with you men should take time
heal men need to heal as well don't make
rational decisions this isn't decisions
but again as men we have this sexual
drive and we have to protect ourselves
from zner I know many brothers who
divorce and like bro I can't like it's
been 5 months 6 months Etc I need a
woman in my life and that's why and I'll
end on this note most of the times you
see single mothers who have not been
married for years you will never find a
single father a single man single father
who goes on for years without getting
married this shows you that this is how
we are created and these rumors of him
marrying a Hindu woman it's just
speculation and rumors and he I'm sure
very knows he's a religious man which
you saw in the podcast he clearly said
that he's a practicing person and I
doubt he knows that you know marrying a
mush woman is it's it's Haram commit Z
it's not allowed for a Muslim man and a
Muslim woman for that matter that's all
I wanted to say inah may Allah subh
correct their Affairs and give him the
best in his life and the Hereafter in
divorce happens it's a part of life
there's nothing wrong with that learn
lessons and move on that was my two pens
piece the reason why I to touch up on
this is for sisters to best understand
the psychology of their husbands and not
fight the hormone just as I would not
tell a a husband to divorce his wife cuz
she talks a lot and she's emotional she
gives him a hard timee my friend the
next man you're going to Mar the next
woman you're going to marry is going to
be the same issue so that's the reason
why I tell my sisters you divorcing your
husband cuz he wants to get married
again you're want to run away from the
problem it's going to come back in a
different form and another man who's
going to do in a different way that's
all I want to say